cérémonie dix ans après la chute du mur
de berlin le bilan est en effet
contrastée
les habitants de l'ancienne allemagne de
l'est n'oublie pas la conquête de la
liberté mais il regrette d'avoir été
aussi mal intégrés dans la société
à leipzig la deuxième ville de l'ex rda
ce que l'on appelle les aussi condamne
l'arrogance des allemands venus de
l'ouest le reportage sur place de mme
emna hintermann et robin teboul lie
psych cache une grande fierté c'est
d'ici que tout est parti en 89
les grandes manifestations contre le
régime avec des milliers de personnes
c'était là sous la protection de
l'église saint-nicolas son pasteur et
aero aujourd'hui encore pour beaucoup
disant trahi les déçus mais il ne
regrette pas son engagement parmi les
dissidents retourner avec un éclat de
rire le mur personne ne veut revenir au
delà brémond à la pauvreté avec le temps
ça forcément sans toilettes ça on
n'aurait plus roulante est celle lui
aussi le prix de la liberté
il était dans les rangs de l'opposition
à 89 aujourd'hui il veut aller plus loin
dans la réunification de la nation et il
ya beaucoup d'injustice sociale
à l'est la route de la réunification est
pavé de désillusions roland qu est élu
sur la liste écologiste regrette cette
envie de copier l'ouest à tout prix
énormément de gens rêvent et de l'ouest
parce que ça semblait plus beau parce
que les gens vivaient mieux et il y
avait un paquet de gens qui voulaient
d'abord la liberté marghi conduit
aujourd'hui nos voitures de luxe elle
avait une trabant quand le mur est tombé
elle habite toujours près de l'ancienne
caserne soviétique mais l'endroit est
devenu selon elle envahi par des petits
voyous comme son mari chauffeur routier
elle s'inquiète de la montée de la
criminalité mais pour rien au monde il
ne voudrait revenir en arrière
aujourd'hui un encore père quand on
passe une frontière
c'est encore en nous ça quand on arrive
à la frontière on se croit toujours
obligé d'arrêter la voiture de sortir
les papiers même si personne ne cherche
à le contrôler quand on arrive par
exemple de la forêt noire pour aller à
strasbourg
comme d'autres ici ce qu'elle regrette
c'est l'absence de chaleur dans les
relations avec les allemands de l'ouest
regardons quand on se demande qu'est ce
qui la convainc sûr pour nous ça ne
compte pas non on avait une très bon et
on en n'est pas mort qu'est ce que c'est
leur problème aux allemands de l'ouest
ils prennent un avocat pour tout et
n'importe quoi quand la vue d'un de
jardin les dérange
non franchement on n'a pas du tout le
même préoccupation vraiment on n'a rien
à voir avec al est dix ans après on
assume sa différence